we honor tonight we honor Ellen with the
Human Rights Campaign 1997 civil rights
Leadership Award we honor her for the
gift she gives us to bridge every
generation and embrace the truth about
lesbians and gays yep Ellen we are gay
and gay friendly ladies and gentlemen
Ellen DeGeneres
[Applause]
No
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
it's good you clap that long because my
speech is not nearly as long as anybody
else's so this this is a so new to me
and I've just been sitting here in awe
of the eloquence of everyone up here and
I shouldn't be up here at all and and I
do understand that this is really a you
you thought you were honoring me by
doing this but I got to tell you since I
found out about it I have been stressing
out over what to say for so long and I'm
trying to figure it out I I am honored
and Elizabeth Burch thank you so much
for everything that you have done and
continue to do
[Applause]
and I am honored thank you very much to
the Human Rights Campaign for this I am
NOT the first gay person to take a stand
to just basically be honest about Who I
am and I understand that there's a
greater impact because I'm on television
then we place a lot of importance on
celebrity I could be a gay person who
came out at some other job and I might
not be standing here I might have been
fired I mean it's it's it's amazing
oh I care about you
[Applause]
it really is wild for me to be standing
here this has not been an easy journey
for me at all I lived with a sense of
shame for a long long time every single
interview I did I dodged that dreaded
question are you gay I tried to be witty
I tried to find ways to get around it
and and my answer was always my private
life is my private life and it is but my
sexuality is as much a part of me as my
skin color
[Applause]
[Music]
you know we we do whatever it takes you
know we try to justify why it's
important and I tried for a long time to
justify why it should be hidden for as
long as I could and then I finally got
to a point where it was more important
for me to live my life honestly and and
to be proud of Who I am than my fame and
ironically as soon as I was honest I
became more famous which you know
so much for those people who said that
it would ruin my career
[Applause]
I I really I felt like I was risking
everything you know because I had been
warned for so long about what I was
gonna do and I was willing to risk all
and and I was I got more than I could
have possibly even imagined my life is
so good and I found love and what's more
important than that
[Applause]
I hear stories all the time now you know
it's amazing what it does when you open
up people come to you and I hear stories
and I and I get letters from people who
tell me how I've touched their life and
in some way and I got a letter from a 76
year old lesbian who said she can't
believe this happened in her lifetime
you know
and me being new to all this didn't know
that there were lesbians 76 years old so
it was all enlightening
I mean it's amazing you know I this man
walked up to me and you know on the
street and he was you know 70s or 80s if
he's watching maybe he was in his 50s I
don't want to offend anybody he was
older but he said you know I couldn't
love or respect you more and I have
everywhere I go I walk down the street
you know even in New York the past week
and I have construction workers giving
me the thumbs up I have people screaming
out as they pass in the car giving me
thumbs up I I have men and women you
know straight gay black white everybody
coming up saying thank you and I end and
keep it up and congratulations I have
children coming up and just saying we
think you're funny you know
[Applause]
yeah ii-i've made it a contribution you
know it I got into this business very
accidentally and and it worked out very
well for me but I really a lot of people
get in it for the for the success the
fame and and I you realize that that's
not really what life is about when you
make the kind of change that that
happened in my life when I when I did
this my whole life turned around and I
know I've done something I know when I
leave here I've really done something it
feels good and I never wanted to be an
activist I just wanted to entertain
people I just wanted to make people feel
good but since I've witnessed the
discrimination and the double standards
and and heard about the statistics for
gay teen suicides I've had to rethink
that and so if by standing up for what I
think is right makes me an activist I'm
an activist
[Applause]
I just
just have one more thing to say look
what you've done
I just I just really I can't I was gonna
just get up here and wing it and today
like you know it's four o'clock I'm
writing this and thinking I hope I
remembered and I just you know and I'm
being questioned when I walk in by the
press about the president being here and
it I'm he was amazing it was it was
amazing and it was so touching and
inspired by him just in case there's any
questions I'm gay just to let everybody
know for sure how cool was that
but I'm questioned about it I don't
understand how people don't see it and
yet you know wasn't too long ago when I
was scared to death to come out I was
scared out of my mind I mean the kind of
thing that happened to the president
when people stand up and start screaming
out I used to fear that when I would do
stand-up I would I would come for an
encore and people would be allowed to
just ask me questions for as long as
they wanted I would just talk to the
audience and every night when I went out
there I feared someone standing up and
saying you're gay aren't you or it
scared the hell out of me and yet I
would not come out and so I do
understand it because it's it's hard but
I just I guess all I would like to say
to people is you know the world is full
of diversity let's not just accept that
let's embrace it and I thank you all
very very much for this it means so much
to me thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]